taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds welcome
to taste buds taste buddies my name is
joe derosa and i'm joe derosa
you just setting the tone setting the
tone babe oh okay all right there you go
absolutely
goofy that's a goofball we need it
we need it today it is a miserable day
outside oh it's like 114 degrees
out there it's horrible traffic
everywhere me and pimp got here like
i think an hour late each or something
like that
it was traffic was brutal oh god
i just walk around the house in the
bathroom waiting for you guys
it just really sucks out there today i
ate four pieces of kfc for breakfast
cold well that would imply you had kfc
for dinner
yeah i had it for dinner last night too
oh you know i've been really wanting kfc
i just i might have to drive out to my
folks tonight after this and i didn't
know if i was going to go home and
it was like sitting there and i didn't
have much in the house how close did you
get the kfc delivered through an app or
did you go get it
i had it delivered it was 98 degrees
yesterday
yeah it would give you me just one more
night una noche yeah poor bastard who
had to deliver it i felt bad did nicolas
deliver it uh
it was i'm going to stop all my puns
with 98 degrees because oh 90 nobody
needs them oh i get it nobody needs them
and they're all they also didn't make
sense uh i never knew any of their
uh songs that's these new apps are
dangerous when you can start just
getting like
our whole lives fast food cannot be
delivered and now it's just like
anything you want
so what do you do what do you do when
you get to the delivery and you're
eating solo is a bucket involved
oh yeah it still involves a bucket well
they have something called the 20
family fill up yeah you can't beat it
it's eight pieces of chicken
yeah that's why i love it and three
large sizes that the single guys order
in the 20
family phillips yeah i love that you
said that you're like well they got
something i like to order it's
i think they're targeting me it's called
the 20 family fill up
i sit i eat it alone in the dark over
over the course of three days
basically no if you can't beat it it's
such a deal it's an eight it's eight
pieces three large sides it's like it's
like why would you
if you got it and you gotta purchase for
the life you want not the light you food
yeah but if also but if you got a
four-piece meal yeah it would be like
fifteen dollars right and you know what
you don't want because it just traveled
45 minutes right in a in a paper cup so
what's the deal
20 bucks kfc shout out kfc shout outs to
casey if you're watching and we know
that you are
shouts to popeyes too though i've never
had them
oh my god is popeyes based on popeye the
cartoon character
yes then why is he on none of the
branding or is he uh or do i not know he
was at one point
are you telling me that they want us to
look at the
look at the font that's popeye fun right
everyone assumes puppies is named for
the cartoon character but the honor
actually goes to a fictional 70s
detective
founder al copeland named his place for
gene hackman's oh popeye doyle
from the front okay two things one
the the the the the quickness
and the assuredness at which you
answered me that it was about the salem
man
hold on but i've seen popeye i've seen
popeye's
chicken stuff pop in that that's the
popeye's logo
but i've also seen popeye's face on
stuff like from what's topical clearly
you haven't that was gene hackman's face
definitely uh clearly you have not i
know what
look look at that his face is on the
building no that's got to be
photoshopped
no what you're right popeye's chicken
and biscuits wait wait that's gotta be
fake is that fake or real
it looks real to me it's on the internet
must be real but that is the popeye
font of the sailor man right see the
popeye
unless it's similar i mean we have the
internet at our disposal we need to know
right now
look at this pop by special go to
popeye's wikipedia page
okay popeyes is an american
multinational chain of fried chicken
fast food restaurants
founded in 1972 in nola headquartered in
miami
since 2008 its full brand name is
popeye's louisiana kitchen inc
we've all rejected that as a society and
it was formerly named popeye's chicken
and biscuits
and popeye's famous fried chicken and
biscuits in its
current it is currently a subsidiary of
toronto based
restaurant brands international all
right let's go popeye's his second
largest quick service beyond kfc
let's scroll a little more let's go to
the name maybe
right there history name alvin c
copeland
claimed he claimed he named the story
after the fictional detective jimmy
popeye doyle
okay in the 1970s he might have been
doing that maybe to avoid something yeah
and the fact that they clearly received
a cease and desist that said
add louisiana kitchen to your name right
the company's early brand became deeply
tied to the cartoon star with its
sponsorship of the popeye
pals children's show in new orleans and
the character appeared on items from
packaging to racing boats
see the chain later required acquired
rights to use popeye the sailor for
marketing
and used it for 35 years there you go oh
okay so i wasn't talking about that's
why instead of
before i piled on with you i said let's
go to the videotape
don't apologize i have nothing to
apologize for yeah
i did the research i came back the right
way you should be
applauding me for handling this in a way
before to be honest with you so anyway
so he claimed it was popeye doyle a gene
hackman's character
from the christians he claimed his fast
casual
chicken dining restaurants were that of
the detective from the french connection
film in 71 outrageous but then went in
and bought the rights to the sailor man
yeah and used that for 35 years and
that's probably when they took on the
the font well i would i would suppose so
who are you detective pop by doyle the
way you just solved that mystery well no
but your claws are out i guess
jesus christ i shouldn't be i should go
easy on you today because you are gonna
get
just smeared today
i don't know what you're thinking you
know why i think the only chance i have
of not
coming out on top here is because let's
just be bold and let's just be
let's just be honest with them let's
tell them right now i took
they'd love to guess who we took who do
you think i took martini
joe's taking mark they're all going to
say i took martini they're all going to
say it
they all said i took pretzels i think
you're right i think they're right
because i think that they think that
you'll have some
air of snootiness to you with the
martini because that's what you project
and they'll think that i'm part spanish
and so that's the the drink of my people
uh but what what i think is is that you
might skew margarita
uh popularity because i think
social media is a young person's game
and i think more people
more young people are in in tune and a
margarita is more relevant to younger
people
you got older people you know a little
more sophisticated it's a little more of
a classic cocktail
it's someone who enjoys their spirits
and who has been a drinker for a long
time
it was martini was the king of all kings
of drinks
for the longest time ever it's the drink
of james bond it's the drink of the
business lunch
uh the two the two the two martini lunch
you know what i mean it's mergers and
acquisitions
people are moving and shaking it's it's
people in evening gowns it's weddings
it's
it's sophistication so it's going to be
interesting because whiskey is currently
the most popular spirit in the u.s
market
uh jack daniels being the most into bran
in demand brand
my favorite booze of all time uh rum is
the second
most popular that blows my bees off
because
i worked in a bar for a decade and
uh vodka reigns supreme now martini
skewed split many different ways gin
jim you want to talk you want to talk
your classic old-school drinks it's it's
all gin martinis
vodka is the secondary martini it's the
martini i prefer
it's the only type of martini i'll drink
but same but i think
nowadays i think that jim martini is
going back to play it against sam
but you're talking about this thing in
the sense of playing against sam you're
talking about the history and
how it reigns supreme forever that was
the gin martini
in this day and age i mean look let's
just start with the obvious
we live in new york city a decade ago
we're having this debate while mad men
was in its stride
you're taking a bath you're nuts they
were they were drinking whiskey on the
rocks scotch was mad men
yeah you know what i saw in the in the
biz in the biz
is vodka i would go through double any
other liquor until
jamison ended up having this renaissance
uh
about but no really like it became like
i don't know like hipsters co-opted it
and then it's spread out from there
but everybody loves potatoes and soda
tito's is the newest vodka to really
take a market share
but i could say that when i was in the
bar the second
most sold liquor i would have or if not
closely tied to vodka would be
a whiskey in the form of an irish
whiskey in the form of jameson
so it's it's it's very uh telling to me
that this is saying that that that
would you say was number whiskey and rum
on this jack daniels
most of demand and then rum is second
most popular
well now look gin is definitely the
least the le i mean
if you're not having a gemini gin is
it's
a gin and tonic and it's gin in a
specialty cocktail
but nobody's gin is not the the the
licorice
parties it's not the liquor of choice at
events i got a friend that drinks
gin gimlets they're his favorite drink
and it's just i i just can't do it you
have a gibson
what's that with the onions with the
cocktail disgusting
no i never had it it looks so gross i
love onions too
but not in my drink so it wasn't you you
love onions but not everybody ever
intrigued you
but it's a cocktail onion it's not
really no the idea of an onion in my
drink is so gross to me i can't even
wait there's an onion in my drink but
let me tell you let's start with the
obvious of why you're going to get
clobbered today
we live in new york city you walk
through new york city
have you ever seen a sandwich board in
front of a bar
that says come on in for
frozen martini come on in i know you
were coming with the frozen margarita
come on in for
you know martinis all day cinco de mayo
we got martinis
you got your day at sick of demaio i get
that and and i see it on the sandwich
boards but you're talking downtown babe
you go to um midtown oh you get even
heavier
you go midtown you go uptown i think
you're tapping into the martini market
first of all up by the park it's
martini's all day or a day you are
crazy what do you mean you got old money
up there you are crazy you're going up
to the roof of lincoln center
you're going up to the roof of lincoln
center to that bar that is the
waterfalls in it
and you're sitting outside you're
telling me the the people up there the
hotties up there drinking
martinis are you nuts here's what i'm
telling you i'm telling you
that 23rd street to
58th street you got midtown you got
steak houses
you got lunches you got offices those
people are pounding martinis
downtown you got some livelihood you got
some youth
you got some outdoor cafes you know i
got i think margarita has a stronghold
ty breakup we're going uptown you're
you're you're you're you're putting
again we're talking just new york you're
putting way you're putting way too much
uh um uh stake on the businessman
contingent
of uptown because because i'll tell you
this
that is a very specific businessman
contingent all right
you go into gramercy for example that's
a businessman
uh neighborhood okay that's gonna be
margaritas all day long you're not going
to catch one of those gramercy kids
drinking a martini
not one of them by the way pimp just
pointed out the most popular drink in
new york state is a vodka fizz
okay what it well that doesn't make it
who took that who took that
uh survey look i've never even heard
i've looks a little martini
like a slow gin fizz it's like a ricky
slogen is red
no but i'm just saying it's the concept
of a fizz like it's like but i'll tell
you i've i've
that is that can't be true what is it
just club soda vodka and
and and lemon seems like it that's it
i don't know about that but honestly it
sounds refreshing and i'd like one right
now i know i want one real bad right now
it looks really good we should go make
them and come back we should oh
let's make vodka fizzy we never have we
always sipping whiskey or a beer but we
never make a nice
cocktail i feel bad we're holding pimp
up if we stop and go make drinks
you think pimp doesn't want a gin fizz i
mean a
vodka fizz wait wait wait let me do this
no let's go
but i was i
when we get back now i can't think of
anything but the vodka fish all right
fine but i was really going to go on a
thing about how martini's classy
no i have a look today i took notes and
i did notes for margarita and martini
stay tuned
it tastes like a margarita of course it
does not
it tastes way closer to a margarita than
it is vodka soda
with mint simple syrup
lemon and lemon so citrus sugar flavor
uh it tastes like vodka to me though but
it tastes way closer to our
margarita all right am i wrong no i
think it tastes more like a martini
because it's vodka and i taste straight
vodka nearly
you i don't need to agree with you that
the drink i just made tastes more like a
margarita has no bearing on this episode
it's not salty at all margarita
too sweet too sour
too salty that's that's trip twos
well look but the salt rim glass
everyone should love shaking a leg at
that they love it
give me a break frozen just getting
blasted with sodium in the middle of
sipping on tequila
frozen strawberry margarita i mean it
looks like it's your life yeah i have
but let me tell you i have a notes i
have notes on frozen
frozen margarita is a scam i wrote you
can maybe have one before it's gross
uh yeah i mean i'm not saying it's wrong
i'm not saying it's something you knock
back one after the next it's like eating
three bowls of ice cream in a row or
something but
it's a wonderful treat okay let me go
down my margarita list
i told you most times they're too sweet
too sour too salty for me they give me
instant heartburn and i'm sure they do
that to many people across the globe
okay too salty he says with it with it
with a drink that has olive juice in it
and he's saying all i mean when you salt
that rim
and you're throwing rock salt right on
your tongue like as you're trying to sip
a drink i get that it's like
the first sip is always like oh a little
salty thing to mix in with the but then
after that you're just
you're just consuming rock salt with
every sip
and here's why and here's wine this is
what i do with the salted glass
i lick away two areas two spaces to get
a nice two-salt sip
okay or two sip salts however you want
to put it
okay and then i keep that clearing and
then i go from that clearing
and when i go from that clearing a grain
here or there gets pulled in
and it's very nice oh and you think
that's like that's how you measure what
your insult intake is
yeah i don't know what i don't go around
the entire world that's running down
every the whole perimeter of the glass
the whole circumference and then five
minutes in
you got salt all over your hands with
lime juice running down if they
go all over your hands what are you
doing with these drinks
i'm sorry my drink is way more
sophisticated i can have it up in a stem
glass and i hold it with two fingers and
nothing gets on me whatsoever
nothing gets on you with a margarita
it's a sloppy drink it's not a sloppy
drink
uh hangover city by the way when you're
mixing sour mix and and all that other
stuff and tequila
one two tequila two tequila three
tequila watcho
four floor joe but try to get a try to
get a skinny margarita then
and no hangover whatsoever i'm not
traipsing around town ordering skinny
margaritas nobody is i mean
this isn't an episode of sex silver no
because they drink teenies by the way
apple teeny i'm sure they drink coffee
well that's
oh i didn't even i'm i'm going up
against you
and i thought i was with a classic i
know you are olive
i know you're saying don't use your sex
in the city but hold on a second now
because if you're throwing in frozens
and strawberries and the like
then look out because i'll come to the
party what happened
straight up espresso martial straight up
margarita
straight up margarita by the way is
fresh lime juice it's none of that sour
mix
i understand that okay what are you
doing so there's a hero hangover we
didn't make a distinction in the polls
because if i got espresso martini apple
teeny
all the other stuff in there we're going
straight ups we're going straight up i'm
just saying
you're going to share those sex in the
city in my face we should have in the
polls put
original martini original margarita we
shot ourselves in the foot now i don't
think so i think
folks it's time for work it's time for
play it's summer time
all right and a lot of you're going to
be on the move that's what you do in the
summer you're going to the beach you're
going to the barbecue you're going to
the store
you're going to the house you're going
all over the place and you want your
music you want your podcasts
and you want convenience that's where
raycons come in i like these
devices it's a great little set of
wireless earbuds
they're bluetooth obviously they're
giving you crisp
powerful beats at half the price my
favorite thing and i will just jump in
here
because i do have a favorite thing about
my raycons and it is the battery
it's the battery because i have other
earbuds that claim to have long battery
life
and they always screw me but i have
taken raycon's on a weekend trip with me
and i have charged him prior and i have
come home with like half the battery
life left it's ridiculous
my favorite part is the half the price i
like that we have two different
favorites
right but then also your favorite thing
is great for me and my favorite thing is
great for you
half the price of these other premium
brands better battery life
raycons are built to go wherever you go
with a quick and seamless
bluetooth pairing and a compact charging
case of course
so listen up let's get you 15 off
all of their products okay just because
you're listening to our show here
you go to buy rakon.com tastebuds that's
by raycon dot com slash taste buds
and at that url you're going to get 15
off your entire raycon order
it's such a good deal so just go grab a
pair grab a spare
get some here get some there that's 15
off at buyracon.com
tastebuds by raycon.com tastebuds
better help better help better help i
like this
service quite a bit i like what they're
doing over at betterhelp
because look let's let's be honest
people
a lot of people these days have stuff
that's interfering
with their happiness uh or something
that's preventing them from achieving
their goals and that's why i'm proud
that this podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp betterhelp will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
this is not a crisis line it's not a
self-help it's professional counseling
that it's done all securely online so it
takes
a lot of the bureaucratic stuff you'd
have to go through to find some help for
yourself
out of the equation puts it right in
your hands gives you control
and gives you a broad range of expertise
available which may not be
locally available in your area that's
the thing about the online stuff is that
you can have way more
uh experts at your fingertips than you
would have locally where you are so
and i like that you can by the way how
uh
uh hastened this process is that you can
move quickly because i
went to better help to talk about a man
in my life
his name's christa stefano he's awful
yeah and you needed you needed an expert
to talk to
yeah i needed an expert to talk to
because i couldn't believe that a man
like this actually walked the earth
and i was able to get right in there and
talk about chris and uh
and make things right for myself uh and
learn how to accept
a heavy quotes person like this
people are responding to better help we
see it through the podcast
i see it in other ads i hear people
talking about it they even right here
they tell us that they are actually
recruiting
additional counselors in every single
state so get on the wagon here
get that not that you get on the train
uh visit it's help too it's not health
so it's visit betterhelp.com
tastebuds that's betterhelp help join
over a million people who have taken
charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for you guys
taste bud listeners get 10 off the first
month
that's uh betterhelphelp.com
taste buds why not try it out i have
margarita is for amateur hour people
okay margarita is a spring to drink
call the entire country of mexico
amateur hour
no i mean i know it's native to mexico
but everywhere else in the world
margarita is you know what it is it's a
happy hour
uh spring break uh you know
okay guess what a martini is elderly
hour it's
we're at the home we let uncle jake
still have his one martini every day
because he's gonna die soon i have a
margarita is hard to make good at home
it's not yes it is you know it's not
hard to make
but it is if you don't have a shaker and
you have the right ingredients it's
simple syrup lime and tequila but when
people make me a margarita from their
home i'm usually like oh it's good and
i'm like oh this isn't like they do in
the store
like a store and then i'm in the store i
mean an establishment like a bar
restaurant
i i disagree with that but but sure it
is it is a few more ingredients than
than your standard martini
i'd say i'll tell you this i think a
martini is incredibly hard to make if
you're bringing vermouth into the mix
i get every martini extra dry
so do i and dirty because i find that if
you don't do those two steps the martini
can
suck a lot of the time a glass of ice
cold vodka
with just vodka flavor is gross a glass
of ice cold vodka with a lot of vermouth
flavor is really gross
yeah but heavy on the vermouth is the
death kiss to the martini you got to
make sure you have a competent party
people like people don't specify dry
they like a vermouth flavor okay fairy
tales like anything i think it's
dry martini i think a dry martini
dirty is key now here's also the problem
with that
and it then depends on the vodka you're
drinking because i don't like the taste
of tito's straight up i don't mind it
mixed but i don't like it straight
i have to have a kettle one martini or i
don't like a martini
if you have the wrong vodka or even the
wrong olive
flavor or olive juice you're [ __ ]
you're you could make a good margarita
good tasting margarita with
silver cuervo some
sour mix if you had to and some lime
juice you're out the door
sour mix in the margarita i absolutely
hate it listen it's fine it's sugar it's
sour it's just
heartburn then simple syrup and lime
juice also usually when someone's mixing
a margarita they're using [ __ ] tequila
you're not putting in
those beautiful high-quality agave anya
fine i want to i'm fine with a silver
cuervo is a good standard
bottom of the barrel if i'm being honest
okay but the silver cuervo and a martini
is good what i'm saying a lot of times a
margarita is made with
well well alcohol with well tequila
and it's you know unless you're ordering
a like a cadillac
margarita i've never i've never been
able to tell
and uh have i had a bad because what
you're really drinking and what you what
your taste buds are picking up
is just the lime juice the simple syrup
or the sour mix you know i could taste
the taste
dominating the tea you just said you
could never tell what type of no
i said i can't tell that i've had a bad
tequila in it
because the difference is is the tequila
flavor is just
one of many flavors coming through in a
margarita in a
in a vodka martini or a gin martini
dry you better have the exact right gin
or the exact right vodka
because that's all you're tasting but
why wouldn't you have the exact right
you're ordering it
made to order if i'm at a bar i'm going
to pick the vodka i don't think
you don't think i can pick the tequila
one and a margarita no
you just told me you picked corvo silver
i'm nothing against jose
i know you're watching we know you are
i'm saying it that tastes good to me i'm
saying but i also have the option to go
a casa migos or hornitos or an espalone
or whatever
waste is what i'm telling you well
espalone is also just it's like
but my point is you wouldn't get a high
end you wouldn't drink a high-end
tequila
in a mixed margarita you're you're not
you're trying to drink
people drink i'm a big fan of a mezcal
margarita and mezcal only gets so low
in my opinion okay that's true but my
point is for the most part though you're
masking the tequila taste with the other
ingredients
so typically you're mixing a margarita
you're mixing
yeah but you're masking you're mixing
that's why you can't tell what's in it
you're mixing but you're not gonna spend
bucks on a high-end tequila and then mix
all the other [ __ ] in
and mask the taste you want that tequila
pure
and you want it straight so a lot of
times when you're drinking a margarita
you're not really drinking that good i
told you know what's in there you knew
that
i'm sorry i murdered i i might have
complained
about the messy drink this is your drink
that you made
i muddled look at how beautiful i did
this like i sliced
fresh lemon and then i put the lemon
circles in there
and then i i found some spearmint in the
fridge and i muddled it
and i put it in the muddled spearmint
what i should have did and i told you i
made the mistake i should have put it in
the shaker
i should have shook it in the shaker and
i should have let it press it against
the ice but i put it in here i said
beware i asked you if you wanted a straw
i don't want to straw i don't want to
drink it too fast all right well then
just
mine the spearmint it got in my tongue
it's messy
you're like it's like you're in a high
chair at a restaurant look who's talking
this guy can't keep chocolate off his
hands can't keep margaritas salt off his
chin
can't keep rib sauce off his face i'm
getting the mint coming through here
yeah and when the mint comes through
you really got something special here
it's very nice
now let's now let's step it up let's
stop it let's step in
today i made notes let's step into i
know you read some of them i want a
counter point
let's step into the future sit down at
an upscale dinner and order a margarita
you absolutely college girls order them
in yard glass you are nuts
you are nuts yeah if you go to an i want
to drink out of a beautiful stemmed
glass or i want someone to put it
in a three plastic frog
if i go to a high end like chilean type
restaurant spanish
flavored restaurant whatever this guy
he's like if i go to a high-end
margarita
restaurant and i have a margarita i get
a margarita before you're going to the
culture of the restaurant that
the margaritas from getting martinis out
unless you're going to a steakhouse
that's the only place you get a martini
where else do you get a martini
before a meal you get a martini go ahead
any restaurant that has a full service i
understand they can offer it so
they can also offer margaritas when do
you get it
fine dining fine dining fine dining bar
and grills
lunches with steaks martinis it's
steakhouse oysters that's it that's it
seafood that's it margarita is outdoor
patio
maybe mexican food oh you mean all the
time then
constantly for months and months out of
the year outdoor patio
you know how much more you're going this
is what you have how much more you're
going to a casualty
you're taking frozen margaritas out of a
goddamn fire we're not talking about
whatever like you're dr evil and frozen
margarita is
shooting out youtube it's loaded with
sugar ice and the cheapest tequila
you'll find
that are three feet long then they
because they're so delicious
i don't know how they got back they just
hope the cab got them listen to me
listen to me listen to me
so many bad choices are made on the
meals of my
house more frequently do you know how
much more frequently you are sitting at
a bar
that is apropos for the margarita then
you are fine dining at a place that's
apropos the martini
hotel bar martini all the way how often
are you sitting at a hotel bars
a third of my life a third of your life
i'm on the road
for 80 cities a year i'm at a hotel 89
you're a millionaire you're a man
including the case
you're a man you're a man that i have
drank with many times many times
every time it's been in a margarita
situation it has never been a fine
dining situation and my point is
i'm not saying you're not a man that
fine dines i'm not saying i'm not either
but my point is is you are far more
frequently in the environment that is
appropriate for the margarita
than you are for the martini and you
know it and you know it stop
talking like you're only going to have
roots
all the time i don't know what i am when
i go out to dinner i'm i'm usually in a
place that's a martini over margarita
[Music]
huh when you're having your melted ice
cream sandwich that you take out of your
pocket
is that the fine dining you're talking
about when you're eating a plate of
french fries it's not the fine dining
you're talking about
when you have your when you have your
mozzarella sticks margaritas when you're
looking to get messy
you're looking to hook up you drink too
much people vomit margaritas
people make mergers over martinis
oh oh so all the evil in the world can
be connected to this drink
oh that's great don't even get me
started
how many blackout people made
questionable decisions let's talk
on margaritas let's talk poolside let's
talk beach
let's talk boardwalk let's talk summer
let's talk paddy
i got it on i got all your favorite
let's talk grilling
i've got all your favorite activities
unlocked with the margarita i have a
dinner party i'm making you a margarita
i'm making a beautiful cocktail you're
not making me a martini either i got
news for you
martini classy sophisticated most
classic drink of all time
james bond's drink of choice olives
business people close emergency power
lunches when you're celebrating or you
had enough
you pull up a seat at a bar the dive
hotel the martini when people are down
in their luck and they go to a
neighborhood bar and they want to drink
their stars away
it's a martini where people just are
celebrating something
big and they go and they [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
how margarita is celebratory no it's not
a martini no it's not
margaritas margaritas uh i have real
weird hours at work
i'm drinking at one o'clock in the
afternoon i'm on vacation
i'm on a budget a frozen margarita is
like the diarrhea
of cocktails it just slushes around with
tons
you took frozen off the table we agreed
so stop saying you pull
over well i'm telling you the people
online are not going to know this
you're my problem we should vote what
they what we think that they're going to
be voting we shouldn't you said take it
off the table we did
we took frozen off the table it was your
idea i said okay it's off the table stop
bringing it up
but i'll tell you this right now so far
your argument is this my martini is a
better drink
for three reasons number one because it
doesn't taste as sweet as and delicious
margaritas because the worst thing is
nothing number two because the worst
people on earth make horrible deals
carving up the universe
over them and number three because
depressed people when they want to kill
themselves
drink it these are your arguments okay
when people want to get
wasted they just pound margaritas yes
people want to get wasted they get
martinis my point is martini i mean a
margarita is really just like
it this does not have the cachet of a
martini man
it's it's you order that tuxedo it's the
president of classic cocktails oh the
president that's a good example
specification
i'd rather go down president i'm gonna
go down to a hotel lobby with a piano
playing
and my bow tie bills are you stealing i
need a gallon of gown and we hit it off
and then maybe we go upstairs on the
terrace and we have a night cap
i don't want to go to some dive bar on
the street
where people are vomiting and saying
like oh my god yes you're my best friend
that's all we ever hang out
that's unfortunate oh you're so foolish
no it's not
look at this martini is a choice of
drunks
eyes of bud says isabelle on twitter
says a margarita
can symbol partying and relaxing for all
ages over 21. a martini is a dry drink
for people over the age of
70 or someone with literally no i don't
believe that at all
i got it i got news for you i got a peek
at some of these comments you are
getting
career really
pimp where are we at time-wise we're at
30. all right
i think i think uh you know you had your
time with margaritas in your 20s buddy
30s and up you got to side with a
martini what about a beautiful martini
with like a
one of those like a blue cheese olives
or an olive like a prosciutto
you're talking about putting cheese in a
drink it's disgusting you could take a
really long walk off a really really
short beer
if you think that those types of
cocktail martini accoutrements
are not unbelievable you look you open
up a beautiful cocktail menu and there's
there's a a blue cheese a huge blue
cheese olive or
prosciutto makes me ruin a ralph oh
you're insane
it's like having a beautiful drink with
a treat at the end listen to this
he's you're coming you're shooting
sounds into your dreams about this
complaining about the amount of simple
syrup in a margarita and you're talking
about putting
ham into your drink i mean what are we
talking about here
what are you reaching for not ham
prosciutto is ham
it's prosciutto it's ham no it's it's
it's don't
knock it down don't reduce it to ham i
love prosciutto i have a sandwich shop
yeah i'm not putting it meanwhile you
you went off last week that pulled pork
is uh is is is the same you you got
creamed on the boards for that one
because i didn't know where pulled pork
came from i don't sell a pulled pork
sandwich i'm sorry but you have a
sandwich shop and prosciutto is ham
i'm sorry i'm not sorry that i'm not
running honky tonk jim's
uh ripped i had to pick a drink for the
rest of my life and it's either a
margarita or a martini it's a martini
i got to be in the mood for a hungarian
i need something i'm gonna be in the
mood for salamix i
you gotta be in the mood for a martini
dude
you're done you can't have more than two
beauty of the martini
that's the beauty of the margarita you
just sip that martini and you take your
time with it you're gonna rush
you take your time with the margarita
too i'm saying two and i'm out but i'm
saying stop making it sound like the
martini is not the same thing you have
two martinis you're out
i'd rather be martini drunk than
margarita drunk i disagree
margarita drunk is you're gonna hurl
you're gonna have a headache
your stomach and your heart your
heartburn's going your stomach is upset
a martini drunk is this pure smooth
sailing
riding that buzz clean
drunk with some nice treats at the end
of it
uh you get a convenient virtual doctor
consultation
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months
you don't have to leave your home you
don't have to go to the doctor
it's a low cost treatment start at 10
bucks a month
and keeps offers generic versions
prevention is key prevention is key
treatment can take four to six months to
see results so act fast
but what you're doing is preventing the
loss of any more hair
it's reviewed well keep says more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors
and the packaging is is discreet if that
is something that matters to you
if you're ready to take action and
prevent your hair loss go to keeps
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash taste buds to receive your
first month of treatment completely free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash taste
buds
to get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash taste buds
joe talk to me about cuts you say you
love a t-shirt i love a t-shirt
my whole wardrobe is t-shirts i have
hundreds and hundreds of t-shirts i'll
tell you what i really love
a soft t-shirt that's right i am always
on the quest for the perfect t-shirt
just google me and you'll find that out
cuts has done something pretty cool
they've taken the classic men's fashion
staple
which is a plain t-shirt and they've
refined it and they've combined premium
quality with
a minimalist aesthetic i love that
because sometimes you go into the men's
section of a clothing store and you try
to find a t-shirt you can't find
anything it doesn't have like a dragon
on it
some sort of thorn dessert staples too
yeah they have all the
uh the building blocks they got t-shirts
polos hoodies
crew sweatshirts uh there they make them
for the man who works hard and plays
hard
never settles for less and i love that
and they're built for performance in the
board room the bar
the gym cuts clothing it's very very
sharp wherever
the game is taking you in 2016 their
founder
steve barelli shout out stevie b set out
to create clothes ready for every
occasion that the modern man faces he
started by reinventing the t-shirt and
the end result was gq magazine calling
this the only shirt worth wearing
that's right cuts is premium with a
purpose each piece of clothing is
designed
with custom engineered fabric expertly
graded for the perfect fit
arming you for every challenge and
opportunity it's not just a lifestyle
it's not just clothing it's office
leisure apparel for the sport
of business and let me tell you
something office leisure apparel for the
sport of business
sign me up athleisure has taken over my
life
and now now leisure clothing is going
into the office
that's what i'm saying get 15 off your
first order by going to cutsclothing.com
buds that's cuts clothing dot com
slash taste buds cuts clothing dot com
slash taste buds you're gonna get 15
off the only shirt worth wearing
uh martinis are the missionary with eye
contact
margaritas are doggy doggy style with a
ball gag margarita that's not true
bubba kush that's silly had that to say
uh fr farook the governor martini soiree
and casinos james bond margarita hand
knights and holidays any sorority girl
there you go uh margaritas are the
ultimate party drink martinis are a prop
for people who wear boat shoes
throw me a pair of boat shoes put me on
the deck of a yacht hand me a martini
you guys could have fun in your non-ac
east village uh
his favorite place to hang out his
favorite places to hang out
margaritas devil piss margarita's god
sweet supple breast
martini is devil piss martini sorry he's
devil pissed there's no such thing
as martiniville for a reason that's a
great thing
you're going to put margarita i was
waiting for you to mention
margaritaville
because margaritaville can take a walk
too i don't need some campy
poppy [ __ ] lifestyle that no one
adheres to
in in in the vein of margaret margarito
you're going to yeah
never mind the song the chain it's like
an applebee's
martinis tastes like against jimmy
buffett if you're listening and we know
that you all
which is your which is your argument
martinis tastes like loneliness and
sadness this is supporting your the guy
that wants to kill himself dude you give
me a martini with somalis in it by the
time i'm halfway through that i'm in a
better mood you know what i do a lot of
times
as opposed to what the depression
crushing down from a margarita sorry
when i sip a margarita i always like
this
oh no i do do that joe because it's very
sour
it's very tight it's very tart i can't
do margaritas all night long that's for
sure
you could do margaritas all night long
you're you're the mom you ready to
do martinis all that long either that's
what i'm saying no but
i'm not gonna no matter what when i end
my martinis i'm not gonna feel
the disgusting my stomach and my my my
my trachea and my assassin sounds like
you're
gonna feel the way they feel when i sip
a nice beautiful sounds like you have a
weak stomach
and a weak trachea and a weak esophagus
okay that's not the
margarita's fault that's your body's
margarita you have maybe one
maybe with lunch you have them on the
patio you have them on the beach i get
that there are drinking a martini is
like taking a huge gulp to the atlantic
ocean and pretending it's refreshing
that's a great point there's nothing
refreshing about a martini
it's not a grape there's nothing because
martini does not taste like the ocean
it's salty it's a salty drink and it's
not refreshing you are
[ __ ] your glasses with salt with the
martini and you're going to tell me
the first thing the bartender waiter
asks you when you get a martini salt or
no salt
i don't know salt a lot of the time i'm
sorry i don't know where you're going
when you get decent bars but the first
thing a bartender says to me is hi how
are you today
oh okay all right that's cute
margaritas are fun and perfectly
balanced
drinks martinis are just fancy vodka
mixes or gin whatever
you can't eat a meal with a martini but
you know the market is geared toward
younger people
they know nothing of the martini they're
gonna speak out of turn
and be like margaritas or when i don't
guess what the country was built on the
back of your grandfather babe
and grandmother babe i offered you
moscow mule
as your option to go against the
margarita you're here
made you pick martinez no it did it and
you said but
it was a drink for younger people
cannot compete with margarita it has
only crossed over
you said martini i'll quote pimp
martini's a powerhouse babe
it's a powerhouse it is baby we got to
put it up it's a powerhouse it is
what it is martini is a great supreme
well the power went out today buddy all
right you're good you're in your 40s
you're taking margarita over martini
yeah no joe yeah no yeah no no
that's because you're trying to appeal
to a subset of people that you shouldn't
be hanging around with
who are those people the youngins the
youngins yeah
you want to be relevant to these kids
and so you're projecting margarita
you know when you're heart of hearts
you're grinch personified
you're an old curmudgeon and you know
for a fact
that the martini
and bo claims that you're in the bucket
with these people these young kids with
the tick-tock you
head talk is margarita's tick-tock you
have a tv
show where you make your friends go fart
in public
and you're going to accuse me i know you
don't watch people younger
i know you don't watch your show excuse
me yeah that's [ __ ]
you just reduced my show to a fart joke
i'm lucky if i have a couple of dozen of
those
in a decade okay are you
nuts you don't watch my show i watch no
you do
you just made the same critique that
everyone who doesn't watch it does uh
[ __ ] i should make my friends i saw you
spit around
possibly you spit and then go out and
try to carry glasses and fall on the
ground this that
that's that that's for sophisticated old
people
it was funny it was funny i injured my
foot sevilla
that's not the point the point is
you are the physical embodiment of a
martini and you're trying to tell me
you're a margarita guy
i like martini and i'm like martini and
martini
it looks like your great great great
grandfather was phil martini
and he invented it silver you came into
my house
complaining well the only thing if you
had an action figure it'd be like
joe would removable arms legs and his
own martini
it would come with it that would be the
thing that came with your action figure
and you have the
you have the pear you sit there with a
pear
telling me that you're a margarita guy
just because you traipse all over the
village and you see it on
on scene i like this comment and half
hate it margaritas are for people on the
joker's
[Laughter]
give me the margaritas all day oh he's
on my side
but this is the short-sightedness of the
people that thinking of that martinis
again are only for people in boat shoes
on yachts it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous go old new york with me
old new york you're talking about old
money old new york
talking about the most classic of the
two drinks
you're addicted to martini but has a
bigger resume i can't say
everybody thinks it's this stereotype
drink that's only for these people when
your whole argument is
it's this classic drink that's only for
those people that's your whole argument
it's not a refreshing drink you would
never would drink it with a meal
or aside from like maybe a like i said
oysters
uh you would never on a hot day order
one
you it's not a party drink it's not a
drink you see in most bars
at most swanky soirees but this is why
everybody says boats and yachts because
you keep saying something
but do i want to go to literally like
someone's barbecue and
and how to make this so i want to be in
a nice evening game
how to make this clear all you know is
trash do you understand that
it's trash you're defending the truth
you're trying to make it sound like
you're in these
when you're talking about going on the
road you're making it sound like you're
standing
in these in these oak line hotels with
you're not
you're staying you're staying in the
dumps we all stand
no i'm sorry to tell you but i'm not
that i know but there's no pianos you're
in a w come on you're in a w
yeah it depends all right let's see
what's available let's go to the polls
tell me right now i go the way of james
bond
um i know i'm a classic fella hopefully
i'm getting better with age
i can wear i'm versatile i can wear a
tuxedo
or a pair of jeans and nice dungarees
dungarees as much 11 500 votes pam
us to the polls uh i'm gonna get creamed
because of the young
because young people are on social media
holy
[ __ ] oh
that's gonna another dropping from
[Music]
82.5 margarita against 17.5
martini arguably our greatest defeat
i've greatly misjudged that that's
wildly misjudged it's been that way
since five minutes in
no oh i am what you have a great poker
face
i am wild i wildly miss this is gonna be
a real hard shot to the cumulative stats
did you see the stats they were putting
out this week this is gonna be a hard
this is gonna
because that's gonna that's gonna skew
oh that's bad
that's bad that's bad well i guess i'm
out of touch
and i'm very curious too as a fun
bonus poll that's bad as a fun bonus
poll
as a fun bonus poll i think we should
put out at some point
margarita versus moscow mule and i want
to see what happens because i want to
see how much closer you would have been
on the museum
i don't know the mule i mean those are
popular dude
i don't know why you backed out of this
video i don't think the mule is as
as all present as a margarita
i really do believe though that the the
the the disparity and percentage points
here was
heavily contributed to the fact that
younger people are on social media yeah
well
i don't think that's a true litmus test
you know what's funny
it doesn't really matter does it when
you're talking like food
you know what i mean like it's like
whatever but when you're talking drinks
you know what it is not not all people
are that sophisticated
sorry joe i'm gonna lean in on the
sophisticated 18 percent of our
listeners
sophistication straight trash
show's over still love you
i still love you i love you too
i'll do the we'll do the merch
announcements i still love you i love
you too
now drop it and make the merch
announcement no no
no no no make the merch announcement i
will but i just want to say
that most of our audience and god god
bless you because we love you for who
you are
and you don't have to defend yourself
but from this from this
these statistics this information that
we just got i now realize that under 20
of our listeners are sophisticated
that's fine it is what it is the only
people that
message me about this show are 49 year
old men
who i don't know who these young folks
are
listening are that's not true i'm sorry
when someone messages you they
lead with their age and sex so are you
asking them this is a weird thing you
just said to me plug the merch please
okay guys okay now here's the thing
we are going to start producing merch
and we have our ideas
for what we want to put them on whether
they be hoodies or t-shirts or
glasses or fun things and we have our
ideas about what we want to do
you know yes the logo yes the name of
the show but we want to make some
unique merch based on episodes things
we've said that you guys have latched on
to
fights any little thing that like has
has become
lore uh or or you know little like taste
buds can
and amongst us so we want to source you
guys to see
your suggestions for merch so hit us up
with
what type of merch you want and then
what you would love to see
on the merch again whether it is a
saying
a phrase a moment from the show a
picture
a food whatev whatever it may be get
creative uh tell us what
has has uh you know resonated resonated
was the word i was looking for thank you
joe
uh with you the most and so we're gonna
use that to help us
so you guys influence the merchant we
give you guys what you want so please
write that in the comments
uh among your other stuff but hit us
with as many things you want also hit us
in the comments
with uh some matches you want to see
because we have an email
we've been looking at it info
tastebudspod.com that's
infotastebudspod.com
email us there with your merch ideas
like sal said whatever
resonated with you was it was it one of
the battles the title was it a phrase
anything put merch in the subject line
yeah and then if you want to suggest a
future match
just put match up in the subject line
and send us your ideas because we saw a
few good ones that we think we might use
and
why not we want to throw it back to you
guys yeah awesome all right guys we'll
see you next time
you're unsophisticated they coming to
the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds